the biggest thing that I struggled with
at the beginning was belief and still
now but I'm a lot more confident have
more self-belief now than I did 5 years
ago or 10 years ago or whatever when I
started my channel there was no YouTuber
with a million subscribers like it
wasn't even a thing I was just making
videos just because I wanted to serve
like if 50 people saw the video like wow
50 people saw that's great let's go but
it's still the thing that I need most
for the next level and I find that's
constant if your main thing is Pivot
your biggest strength is that you
pivoted your biggest strength is that
you helped other people pivot and the
biggest thing holding you back is the
next pivot what's the next pivot